no matter where you land on the recently
released Ghostbusters remake there's one
thing we can all agree on busting makes
me feel good what does it I can
personally attest to how dancing to the
Ghostbusters theme song in a well-lit
puppetry and makes me feel good real
good but I'm not ready to let ray parker
jr. dictate my feelings on the umbrella
action of busting so I set out to play
every Ghostbusters game ever made then I
saw how many there were so I just did
like five produced in 1984 the first
Ghostbusters game was originally
released for the Commodore 64 and Atari
800 the game was later ported to several
systems including the Atari 2600 sega
master system and the nes which is the
most notorious version and that's the
one i played after spending ten minutes
playing what i thought was a pacman
clone because grid ghosts etc i realized
that i could select different buildings
on the map which would take me to a
brief driving section in which i dodge
ecto-1 through dance Manhattan traffic
all while the grating chiptune
Ghostbusters theme song played on a loop
as Ghostbusters is always prided itself
on realism I was happy to find that my
car could run out of fuel and I'd be
treated to a cutscene of two pixelated
Buster's pushing the car to the nearest
service station once I arrived at my
first stop I loaded up on proton beams a
ghost vacuum and a bunch of ghosts food
ready to go out and feel good through
busting
oh did you not realize there was a
second screen on that shop screen
remember how in ocarina of time when you
need to get up death mountain but the
only way to buy the hylian shield is to
navigate to the hidden menu with the
shop in the bazaar it was at this point
that I threw my hands up in frustration
and gave up busting makes me [ __ ]
angry because Seeger had to live up to
their slogan of doing what Nintendo they
developed and released a good
Ghostbusters game for the Mega Drive /
Genesis in 1990 titled simply
ghostbusters the game allows you to
choose to play as one of three
Ghostbusters raised stance Peter Venkman
and Egon Spengler with the very
noticeable absence of winston zeddemore
and partake in platforming shooter
contra light action as you answer calls
about an increase in paranormal presence
around the city gameplay is simple
action platforming that sees you blast
away at common low-level ghosts will
navigating treacherous platforms in MC
Escher designed houses each level has a
midpoint boss that once defeated is able
to be captured in a ghost trap in order
to replenish your character's energy
before you move on to the final boss
maybe it's been too long between 2d
action platformer drinks but I found
Ghostbusters to be brutally hard getting
hit by an enemy causes your chosen Ghost
Buster to jump back far enough to send
you falling off the ledge you took 10
minutes planning on to and remember
aiming with the d-pad remember how
responsive it is to aim on a diagonal
and how it doesn't hurt your thumbs at
all Buster makes my thumbs booster okay
let's get this out of the way straight
up this game has flaws but holy [ __ ] if
it doesn't make you feel like a
Ghostbuster set two years after the
conclusion of ghostbusters 2
Ghostbusters the video game casts
players as the rookie to the established
New York City Ghostbusters Venkman
insists that you only be referred to as
rookie in case something happens to you
while you're testing the new
experimental equipment on your first day
a massive pke event hits New York City
and it's up to you in the og crew to
answer the call of a spooked City the
game reunites the original Ghostbusters
including the impossible to get a hold
of Bill Murray and was scripted by
original writers dan Aykroyd and Harold
Ramis let me tell you about the opening
hour or so of Ghostbusters the video
game the very first thing you do is
slide down a fireman's pole at gbh q and
if you like me immediately run back
upstairs and do it again then you bust
the containment unit unleashing slimer
go to the hotel Sedgwick in order to
recapture him ruin a bunch of [ __ ]
including but not limited to the
managers day a fridge a staircase
General de Gaulle some dudes Bar Mitzvah
then recaptcha slammer just in time to
see that the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man
is back and then you battle him in Times
Square with the god damned Ghostbusters
using the proton pack is so good
blasting the unwieldy particle beam
looks exactly how you remember from the
movies and it's impossible to aim
without causing a serious amount of
damage to the surrounding architecture
and furnishings trapping a ghost is
satisfying as it takes a little bit of
wrangling the while expected with
fishing like Yanks on the right stick
before their successfully caught oh man
I think we all know how this one made me
feel that's right busting makes me feel
good for real it's like ten bucks on
steam go get it right now the latest
Ghostbusters game is a nostalgic trip
down memory lane sure to remind you of a
time when every summer blockbuster a
popular TV series had hastily produced
undercooked and overpriced video game
tie-in Ghostbusters is not a good game
it's not broken or anything I mean if
you move the sticks and you press the
button stuff happens but it's not worth
the 6995 I paid for it set after the
events of the 2016 movie ghostbusters
allows you to choose from one of four
very memorable rookies the big chain gun
fella average assault rifle Joe dual
pistols speedy Sheila and shotgun lady
in order to bust ghosts in a twin stick
shooter with repetitive and overly long
levels after a lame but kind a
good-looking opening cinematic I was let
loose in the old regime anshan the site
of the first case from the movie I shot
my gun and threw grenades all while my
teammates incessantly quipped yes
possessed and I'm like the MVP of EVP in
the 60 minutes I played before my soul
left my body to wander limbo as it
called it would be a better use of its
time I managed to complete two levels
now that's not due to poor performance
on my part but because the second level
is so unnecessarily long and the
characters are so slow that i was sure
the game had glitched and was sending me
through the same open empty squares of
graveyard for 40 minutes dropping ghosts
is achieved by mashing x or a depending
on your platform of choice in order to
increase the score multiplier before the
trap slams shut confining your corporeal
catch to its temporary prison I pride
myself on my button mashing abilities I
mean I was the only one of my friends
not to use a turbo fire or another
person during the torture sequence in
Metal Gear Solid but even I couldn't get
the multiple
about five before my hand would cramp
and I started rethinking every decision
that had led my life to this point I
still reminds me of the time I spent all
my Christmas money on South Park for ps1
so I guess Boston doesn't make you feel
good take that line in the song no one
ever took literally went up like the
video games now if you'll excuse me I'm
off to see if the power of love is an
adequate substitute for train fare